rien de nouveau dans la mode masculine
voilà ce qu'il ne faut plus dit l'homme
en contenir un avantage naguère décrit
barbe redevient aujourd'hui ce qu'elle
n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être la plus
noble conquête de là on se remette à
rencontrer et donc les mondes
cet accessoire pileux qui a toujours été
l'expression d'une époque sensible aux
portera donc là bas mais laquelle
aventurière à la bombe a recommandé à
tous ceux qui aiment la mer et la soupe
de poisson
énigmatique et cruel à la borgia
recommandé aux conquistadors en herbe et
à tous ceux qui se tiennent pour des du
conquérant à la landru propice aux aveux
chuchoter aux longues confidences de
bouche à oreille a malheureusement
ministériel ou impérial à la négus kuala
buron on a le choix mais l'heure est
venue son se raser d'hier aujourd'hui on
se bat
[Musique]